on a eu
une vie remplie
bière
v&o wouter et roger thibault sont
ensemble depuis un demi-siècle en
interne depuis le début
convaincus tracé à 100 tout le reste nos
jours
c'est ça
le 18 juillet 2002 il y avait le temps
ils ont officialisé leur union une
journée mémorable pour plus d'une raison
je vous déclare maintenant conjoint unis
civilement
se tait l'histoire de québec comme a
réalisé sept jours
avant le mariage en rhône avait
vécu beaucoup d'art somain depuis
presque dix ans
ici dans notre voisinage
et
pour nous c'était très important de
d'avoir les mêmes droits
finalement des droits garantis par la
loi 84 contre aucun aucune abstention
et qui ont permis à théo et roger de
combattre l'homophobie dont il était
victime c'était épouvantable
épouvanteur dix ans
dans ma peur
on a eu du fun sur notre maison
un gros caillou dans notre auto c'est
sûr que pour une personne aînée ça
devient très l'eau
au niveau émotif et ça il faut le
dénoncer ce qui était intéressant par
contre a constaté c'est qu'on a des
outils mais au québec
s'il a diminué le harcèlement n'a pas
pour autant disparu mais le couple a
surmonté l'adversité en donnant vie à un
jardin bâti pierre par pierre servent
avant tout de la vie
beaucoup de plaisir
faire le jardin
ça c'est tout la faute de notre mariage
ce sentiment de fierté ils le vivent à
nouveau devant les photos de leur union
le gâteau
vingt ans après téo cultive encore sa
passion pour la haute couture et la
peinture
roger travail quand sa santé le lui
permet sur un nouveau livre racontant
l'histoire d'un jardin de ville où
chaque espèce s'épanouit en liberté ici
à ce mitraillette radio canada montréal